Hello. Thank you for coming. It's a
pleasure being here for all of us. Um,
today I'm going to talk really briefly
but hopefully usefully about what we do
and give you a taste of it as well.
And our philosophical meditation,
which is one of our most loved exercises.
So first we'll talk about what
we do at the school of life,
then we'll talk about what
emotional intelligence is,
how we see it at the school of life.
We'll talk about why it's
so important at work.
And also we'll talk about how we at
the school of life teach emotional
intelligence in our classes, in
our workshops and our events. Um,
and sort of our technique there.
And finally you'll get to try it out so
you'll have a sense of how it works for
you. We're how one of our exercises
works for you in any case. So to start,
let me tell you a little bit about
what we do at the school of life. Um,
we are a global organization dedicated
to developing emotional intelligence and
we have 10 locations around the world,
but we operate in even more countries
than that. We have, um, first of all,
concrete classrooms where people can
go and take workshops and classes on
particular emotional topics as,
as was mentioned.
So we teach things like how to make love
last and the meaning of life and how to
fail or things about how to be calm,
how to cope with anxiety.
We're teaching the types of skills that
you might wish that you had learned in
school but generally aren't covered.
And in particular we're trying to save
people a little bit of time and grief
because these are things that otherwise
we tend to learn sometimes through
really hard experiences.
So we'd like to save you a little bit of
that pain and a little bit of that time
learning by doing some thinking upfront.
Um,
you can see here some of
the things that we do.
That's our classroom in London and
bloom spray and you can always come by.
We've also got a storefront in most of
our places where you can purchase some of
our books and products.
Um,
sometimes we have big events and those
are really interesting on different
emotional topics. And finally we've
got locations in lots of places,
so that's a little map of
where our locations are. Um,
in particular we tend to focus our work
on two areas of life and this guy says
it even better than we do.
This is Sigmund Freud and we're very
fond to Freud in of psychotherapy in
general,
we really believe that it's beneficial
for everyone at some point in their life.
Freud said of his patience, love and
work, work in love. That's all there is.
And by that he meant that on the whole,
that was where people
came to him to talk about.
That was the area in their life where
they really needed to explore and we find
is the same at the school of life.
People come and they want to talk about
how to build fulfilling relationships
and how to make work fulfilling as well.
So over the last 10 years,
because we were founded in 2008
we're just hitting our second decade.
Over the last 10 years,
we've been learning a lot about what
people are concerned about at work,
what tends to trouble then?
What tends to help,
what tends to make work go really well?
And after a while people started
coming to us and saying, you know,
the amazing thing that you taught me
about listening or about empathy or about
patients or about keeping calm,
I'd really love to bring it to my office.
I'd love to bring it to my team. Can you
come in and teach our team that thing?
Or can we do an exercise with my
whole organization about this perhaps.
So we began to sort of develop our
thinking around what people needed in the
workplace and we began to provide
services to businesses, organizations,
and eventually we decided that roughly
there were about 20 things that people
really needed to know in
order to do well at work.
In terms of emotional intelligence,
these are the ones and you can
see that lots of different things.
So things like adaptability, diplomacy,
playfulness, self awareness, resilience,
right?
This is more or less the types of things
that people need to know in order to do
well at work. Um, so we've, we've kind
of become experts in this a little bit.
Hopefully. Uh, we also
do some other things.
These are some other things that we do.
We've got a conference at travel
is about every six months.
We've got a new location for that.
Uh,
we've got really interesting fun games
cards, books, you can see them upstairs.
This was mentioned.
And of course we have our youtube channel,
which has about 3.7 million
subscribers today. Uh,
and you should become one if you like.
And we put out about two videos a
week on different topics in emotional
intelligence.
So we like to bring our message in
lots of different ways and connect with
people in lots of different ways as well.
But I'd like to talk a little bit now
about what it is that we're doing with all
of these different ways of talking
to people. What are we talking about?
What in other words is
emotional intelligence?
This is the really nice formal
definition that we tend to use.
Emotional intelligence is the quality
that enables us to confront with patients,
insight and imagination,
the many problems that we face in our
effective relationship with ourselves and
others. And in this case effective
means having to do with emotions.
So another way I like to think about this
is that we're talking to people about
how to navigate around their own emotions
more gracefully, more thoughtfully,
and also to connect with other people
and other people's emotions in a way
that's more intelligent,
more insightful,
and ultimately more likely
to make things go well.
Now I know that this might sound
a little bit weird to some people.
Some people say that's just strange.
You know,
it's like a little bit of woo magic,
whatever. Uh, maybe this is just a fad.
But actually we really think that this
is something that everyone understands a
little bit intuitively because we can
talk about people we know who have maybe
been very successful at things like
science or even maybe they've gotten quite
wealthy in a particular area or they've
been a really good lawyer or something.
But their personal lives might
be a bit sad or a bit lonely.
They might have screwed up a major
thing with their family or with a
relationship, or maybe they're just
very unimaginative or a little bit, uh,
demanding or cruel in a way that's not
very helpful to them in the long run.
And when this is the case,
when someone's clearly very intelligent
in one area but isn't very good at
navigating their own
emotions or relationships,
that person can be said to be
lacking in emotional intelligence.
So we all have something of an intuitive
sense of what it might mean to have
emotional intelligence and
unfortunately sometimes to lack it. Um,
but I want to talk a little bit more
about what it is concretely that you learn
to do when you have emotional
intelligence and when you develop it.
What exactly are you
learning? Um, first of all,
a major part of emotional intelligence
is some skepticism around our own
emotions.
In other words,
that we're not going to believe
everything that we feel right away.
We might feel afraid,
but we're going to be able to have
a little bit of distance and ask,
should I be afraid?
Right? Or, um, you know,
someone can come to us and we can have a
bit of skepticism about their emotions.
They might be very angry and we're
able to have a little and say,
are they just an obnoxious person that's
always angry or are they really anxious
about something right now?
And this is covering that over.
So we think it's very important to be
able to have a little bit of healthy
skepticism about why we're having the
motions were having and why other people
are having the emotions they're having.
And we know this is a
bit counter cultural.
There are a lot of voices in the world
that say, you know, trust your instincts,
go with your gut instincts. But
at the school of life, we say,
don't trust your instincts. They're
often rubbish, right? Not always,
but it's good to be able
to be skeptical about them.
They can lead us very far astray.
And probably all of us has seen that in
our own lives or in the lives of someone
that we know.
The other thing we're very interested
in which is related and which we talk a
lot about at the school of life,
is that we talk a lot about being aware
of the way our past might be affecting
our current emotional responses.
So we say that emotional intelligence
involves recognition of the importance of
our past and our childhood.
In particular,
you might recognize this if you've
ever been to therapy or even read about
therapy because therapists
believe this as well,
and in particular they believe that
between the ages of zero and six,
a lot of our emotional
apparatus or emotional hardware,
if you like, is formed.
It doesn't mean you can never change
and after the age of six of course,
but it's much, much harder in
the same way that it's much,
much harder for someone
to learn a language once
they're over the age of 20 or
so.
Our minds are shaped a lot
by our childhood and they're
also shaped a lot by our
past.
If we had a very difficult experience
or even a very good one that's likely to
affect how we see things in the future.
And while this isn't ideal
for a lot of reasons,
the most important thing is that
we can become conscious of it.
I also know that some people will be
skeptical about this. I'll say, you know,
that's ridiculous.
I have a really nice linkedin profile
now and I look very professional and
serious and I'm an adult and I can
manage everything. Thank you very much,
Anne and I sympathize because
I sometimes feel that way too,
but I think we can see a little bit of
how our childhood might have affected us
when we get in high periods of stress,
right?
Or sometimes you can even
see when people get drunk.
There are moments when we kind of revert
back to our inner child is a bit like
this, this is a child and this might be
his grown up version of himself. Right?
You can see this in people a little bit
when they're under a lot of pressure.
And so the point is that we're always
going to be acting in very immature ways,
but that we have the potential to do
so when there's a lot of pressure and
therefore we need to become aware a
little bit more of what those ways of
behaving might be.
We might have learned as a child that
people are not going to be very responsive
to our needs.
And actually it makes it very difficult
for us to work in a team once we're
under some stress.
So there are things like this about our
past that emotionally intelligent people
tend to become more aware of and
navigate around to some degree.
Um, I want to talk now more a little bit
about how this works in the workplace,
right? So why is emotional intelligence
important at work? Um, well,
one of the reasons is actually very new.
This is a new period in human history.
In terms of work. It's maybe always been
helpful to have emotional intelligence,
but never more so than now.
And it's probably only going to get
more and more important and one of the
reasons is because we're now
working so much more with our minds.
For most of human history,
we were gathering nuts and fruits
and then suddenly we were farming,
but that was pretty physical and maybe
then we built some pyramids and you,
we did a lot of physical labor,
but after that,
I'm only recently have we started working
in really, really complicated teams.
Most people have started working in
ways that involve talking to people and
convincing them and prioritizing
and managing their own emotions.
All of the sudden,
so much of our work is psychological and
so as a result at the school of life,
we believe that good business requires
good psychology and this is it.
Something that's,
you know,
cute and nice and good to have and maybe
the HR team will do every once in a
while. It's something that's crucial
every single day. It's not a luxury,
it's a necessity.
It's really,
really important because ultimately and
increasingly it's going to be the very
thing that we work on.
Even if our technical skills are great,
this will determine whether you succeed
or don't do so well at the things that
we're working on.
Again,
it's because we used to be doing things
like this and now all of the sudden
after thousands and thousands of years,
a lot of the most important
work in the world,
a lot of the work that most of us
are doing looks more like that.
And that is very complicated.
That involves a lot of guessing,
maybe six or seven steps ahead,
how other people are likely to respond,
how we can persuade them,
how we can convince them,
how we can get along with them,
how we can understand when we're wrong
and why that's very complicated emotional
stuff.
So suddenly our work is psychological.
The quality of the work that we do is
now hugely dependent on our emotional
states of mind.
And as a result,
we need to learn with modesty and courage
and insight how our emotional minds
work and why they so often don't quite.
Um,
in another way of thinking about this is
that the most complicated technologies
on earth don't have anything to do with
all the nice things made here at Google.
They are the people in this
room and out there in the world,
we are the most complicated things and
we need to put ourselves as much as we
can, right? We need to
make sure it's working. Um,
so how do we do that?
That's a good question.
We'll talk to you a little bit about how
we teach emotional intelligence at the
school of life. Um, some people say, well,
what do you mean teaching
emotional intelligence?
Isn't it just something that you
have where you don't have, right?
Either you're charming and you're
good with people and you're good at
communicating and you're calmer, you're
not, and it's just what you're born with.
That's it. Why am I trying
to learn this now? Right?
But we completely disagree
at the school of life.
We actually think these are really
concrete skills. You can learn them,
you can practice them and you can get
better at them until they become second
nature. In a way. We'll talk
about nature more in a second.
And we're not the only people who have
believed this in the course of history.
Here's some funny people who
have definitely believed this.
These are French aristocrats in a salon,
and people like this were trained
for a long period of life, uh,
to be more charming,
better communicators.
They learned some funny things like how
to stand behind a chair in a charming
way, right? But we also learned
how to persuade, how to convince,
how to say no without giving offense.
And it's really not so much about the
concrete skills that they had because you
might need different ones.
Now that you work here.
It's the idea that there are things that
seem natural but really took a lot of
practice and training to get right.
There are things that can
make you more likable.
There are things that can make you
succeed and do better in the world.
So we believe what these
guys believed in a way.
And we also believe what in general
is called the classical approach to
education, which is in contrast to
the romantic approach to education.
The romantic approach to education built
on the romantic movement to the 1800
says, you know, human nature is
wonderful. Let's just have more of it.
All the things that humans
are already good at,
let's develop them and encourage them.
But actually we're very interested
in what you might call second nature,
the thing you develop afterward.
In other words,
we're very interested in the
types of tools we can use,
almost technologies we can use to improve
what otherwise wouldn't be natural for
human beings and theorists
of classical education.
Love to use the metaphor of the tool.
Or in this case it's a pulley, right?
Because no one by nature is fitted
to lift a heavy statue like that.
That's a statue actually, that guy. Um,
but with the right tools you can do it.
And teaching emotional
intelligence is the same way.
You can basically develop
a new type of nature,
a new type of ability
that you never had before.
And that wouldn't necessarily
come natural to you to begin with.
So that's what we're working on.
That'd be tell you a little
bit more about how we do that.
One of the things that we do,
and this is very important when
you're working in groups or an entire
organizations, is that we help to create
a culture of humility. This is really,
really important because otherwise what
happens is you bring people into the
room and you're like,
well,
you're the pessimistic one and you're
the problem and you're the one that's
being really difficult than you're
the problem person in our team.
And then that person of course becomes
very defensive and Aaron else feels very
self righteous and nobody learns anything.
So we work very hard to begin by saying
this thing that we're going to learn
today, whether it's about communication,
whether it's about playfulness,
is a problem and an opportunity for
every single one of us in this room.
All of us have this strange, quirky
thing about us that makes it difficult.
Or in other words, we are all
crazy, right? We're all just nuts.
Barely holding it together.
People some days and all of us need help
on this thing and it's actually really
helpful if someone like the CEO can stand
up and be like, hello, I'm an idiot. Yes,
I'm an idiot. In the following ways,
it's good because first of all,
in most companies,
at least some people are already thinking
that the CEO is a bit of an idiot,
but it's actually really reassuring to
see someone like a CEO say, you know,
I'm aware of my idiocy. It's not
escaped me. I'm, I'm working on it.
And that's true for all of us. We tried
to create a culture where people can say,
I know I have various eccentricities,
you know,
I don't mean crazy of
course about mental health.
I mean human instability in general, but
I'm working on them. I understand them,
I know I'm not perfect.
That creates a really open culture in a
community and and then organization and
then a team.
So we work very hard in the structure of
our workshops and then all the way that
we present our materials to say this
is something everyone can work on,
nobody's perfect at and
everybody can learn.
This really helps us
overcome defensiveness.
We want people to be open to the idea
and actually want to learn and learn new
tools that can help them. Another thing
that we do, and this is very important,
is that we help people
not only learn but repeat,
learn over and over and over again and
practice over and over and over again.
The important skills that
we believe in because um,
a lot of education in the world tends to
think about sort of the human mind is a
bucket.
Like you are going to spend maybe a day
or a week or a year pouring intimate
information and then after a while you've
got it and it's in there and that's
good and you're done and nothing else
is needed. And at the school of life,
especially around emotional skills,
we disagree completely.
We think the human mind is really,
really fragile.
It forgets things really easily. It
means, well, you know, but it slips. Um,
we think we be kind and generous.
And that sounds really great in the moment
when you're listening to someone talk
to you about it.
But then you know,
an hour later you're hungry in two hours
later you have an email and you forget
by the end of the day. So we really think
the human mind is a bit like a sieve,
right?
And as a result,
we think that we need to repeat everything
to do with emotional intelligence
quite a bit. We need to practice
constantly. We need good reminders.
We need an interesting, intelligent,
sensitive, appealing reminders.
Because no matter how wonderful we are,
it is going to slip through our minds.
We are going to need to refresh.
We're not the only people that
believe this either, by the way.
Some of the very first teachers of
emotional intelligence, so to speak,
however flawed in other
ways. We're religions and
religions believe this as well.
They think that people need
to repeat all the time,
that they need to be reminded
to be kind in the morning.
And then after lunch they
need to be reminded again
because they forgot over the
course of lunch. Right? It's
not because people are bad.
They just recognize
this about human beings.
We need to be reminded constantly or
we're going to get home at the end of the
day and snap at our partners
and yell at our children. Um,
and so we kind of base some of
what we do on the structure of, um,
movements like this or a meditation,
things like that,
because we recognize the
value of that aspect.
The other thing we tried to do is
just make it interesting and engaging.
We worked really hard to actually present
things in a way that people will say,
yeah, that's right. That appeals to me.
You can see this a bit in our youtube
channel, of course, which is very popular,
but also in the way that
we do our workshops.
These are some funny slides from our
workshops and they just have really
appealing quotes.
They've interesting historical facts that
you're unlikely to forget. Strange art,
like that funky art there at the
top, you know, um, good metaphors.
The point is we want it to stick in
the brain as long as possible before it
slides this SIF. So we're very,
very interested in beauty as well.
We think beauty brings ideas to life and
that's true of course with these little
products as well.
And all of this is designed ultimately
to help people be more aware of what
they're like.
Um,
people don't need to be perfect at
the end of the day to be emotionally
intelligent.
What they need to do most of all is to
be aware of the ways in which they are
imperfect, to be able to
navigate a little bit better,
to acknowledge when they
might've screwed up,
to look for places where they can improve.
That's the ultimate goal.
None of us will be perfect,
but all of us can be a bit better.
This has to do with self awareness.
We encourage all this regular reflection,
these exercises,
they're all geared in some way towards
self awareness and rather than go on and
on about self awareness,
now I'm actually going to give you a
chance to try it out with one of our most
popular exercises,
the philosophical meditation.
So I'd love to encourage you for a minute.
Um,
it's good to write things down
during this exercise. So if you want,
you might get out something
that you write things down on.
It's your phone or you know,
a little notebook or something like that.
And I'll explain a little
bit about this as well. Um,
a lot of traditional
meditation, especially the
way it's been brought in, uh,
to the West has to do with the
idea of trying to empty our minds.
And in the sounds that can imply that
maybe there's not anything that useful to
know about the things that
are floating around in there.
Maybe we don't need to
investigate them too much.
This is a bit of an overgeneralization.
I know there's very complicated different
strengths of meditation in the east,
but the point is that we sometimes
lose the thread. We might think, oh,
what I need to do to calm down. It's just
not investigate the content of my mind.
But at the school of life we think
is actually really important.
So rather than trying to empty the
mind or become more aware of our body,
although those things
can be useful for people,
sometimes we're actually very interested
in things like downloading the mind and
sorting through the feelings and ideas
that we have and interpreting the
anxieties and hurts and
excitements that might be in there,
but which we haven't fully recognized
and interpreted for ourselves.
We're going to get a
chance to do that today,
at least with one of these sections.
Maybe we'll start with anxiety because
my intuition is that most people have
anxieties, a lot of anxieties
throughout the day. So first of all,
I might say that many
people do this a lot.
Some people that come to the school
of life end up doing this regularly,
maybe for even an hour or so. And it's a
good one to take home and try out again.
I like to say that our exercises
are a bit like Ikea furniture,
so you can take them home with you and
then you kind of construct them in a good
way for yourself there.
But we're just getting a taste now.
You're just getting the pieces now.
So these are the usual three Co, uh,
questions, uh, philosophical
meditation. What am I anxious about?
What am I upset about and
what am I excited about?
They're just good starting questions.
They help us think about what's
going on in our life. Um,
and I'd love to suggest
that we start with this one.
What am I presently anxious about?
So I would suggest that you write down
for a minute or two, as many as you can,
think of things that you're anxious
about. You can do shorthand. So no one,
none of your colleagues know
what it means. You know,
it might just say k where I might just
say 10 30 or something as much shorthand
is you need. And then in a minute we'll
do a little bit more with that list.
Okay.
There's even some suggested categories
here at the top in case you're thinking
of things and can't quite drum
sum up, work, relationships,
family health, sex, money,
things I have to do.
Once you've written down a few,
you might just choose three and the
three are going to be the ones that you
unpack maybe even too,
since it's a short talk, um,
and you're just going to begin
to unpack them a little bit.
It's kind of like separating
out the different strands
of thought that has to do
with that topic. So there's a suggestion
here of how you might do that.
Unpacking anxiety.
You might want to complete the following
sentences around each of those two
things.
Let's say one of them has to do with um,
an argument that you
had with your partner.
So you would complete the
sentences in regards to that thing.
What I'm really afraid will happen is
then you'll think about is it that you're
worried that the relationship
is getting worse?
Is it that you're worried
that there might be a breakup?
that your needs won't be bad?
I'm kind of trying to be as
honest with yourself as possible.
What is the underlying fear? It's not just
that fights are unpleasant, of course.
What ultimately might be the bad thing
after that, you might want to
consider what you want to do about it.
Is there actually something that you
could do that would perhaps reduce the
anxiety or at least take the issue
further in a constructive way?
It's good to first figure out
what you're afraid of though.
Sometimes people jump right to action,
but we need a little bit of skepticism
about the emotions before we can choose
actions wisely
and finally you can move on to the
point about reassurance. So it's con,
it's really containment and reassurance
by which we mean that you're not going
to let the anxiety take over
your whole life and color.
Everything else that's going on,
you're going to begin to bring it
back down to scale. What is, you know,
the limit on this particular anxiety.
So the worst thing that can happen is
in some ways the limit you might think,
okay, absolute worst case we
break up, that would be terrible.
But I guess I would do this and that
case I could see my friends more.
For some people this is very reassuring
because it contains the problem to scale
that is perhaps smaller
than civil war. Right? Um,
we can also think about how you would
cope. That can often be very reassuring.
I would take baths, I would see my friends
more, I would complain to my parents,
whatever it is. Um, this is kind of silly
examples, but you probably have your own.
So think a little bit about
how you might contain your,
your anxiety and maybe offer
yourself some reassurance.
And then in a minute if you like,
you have a chance to just share with the
person next to you how this was for you.
And if you like, you can share the
details. Of course you don't have to.
So in a minute I'll, I'll
open it up. When you're ready,
do turn to someone next to you
and just imagine how this was,
what did you get out of it?
If you'd like,
you can share the details but you
don't have to and then we'll come back
together in a few minutes.
[inaudible]
from just one or two people. What
that was like for you? Was it helpful?
What part of it was helpful? If anything
was helpful or if not, that's okay too.
Yeah, I think you've got a Mike,
can we bring it over? Thank you.
Yeah.
Great.
Hi.
I'm actually going to steal this
gentleman's appointment he made only with
chatting. Um, it was
really beneficial. Um,
I took two to work on.
One was really beneficial because it
made me seem like my worries sort of. Um,
we're a bit insignificant and
I could just like move past it,
but then one went really horrible,
so I just thought in some,
when you pick some worries it
can win. Uh, what, what, uh,
what I'm really afraid what happened
is that bit can get a bit horrible.
Do you know what I mean?
Sometimes it can work both ways,
but I think generally it's like a nice
beneficial way to work through it and
just be able to sort of like prioritize
and work through your words one by one.
It's a really nice way of looking at it,
which I think everyone in this
group maybe hadn't done before.
So it was nice to do it like that.
Yeah. And perhaps a second issue.
There are other ways of thinking about it.
So it's certainly not a cure all,
but nothing really is.
Thanks. Yeah. Thank you.
You begin to also look at the nice things
that are floating around in your mind,
but don't get enough attention.
So in other words,
we're thinking about how sometimes our
mind notices things and it really likes
them and latches onto them for
a minute. But then you know, it,
it forgets in by the end of the day,
you don't remember what it is.
And actually you had a nice intuition
there, but you might lose it.
So these are rather exciting
thoughts. Um, or it might be the,
it's a little bit troubling.
Sometimes we envy someone
that's not very comfortable,
but nevertheless the envious telling us
something about what we might actually
really like to do in the future.
So these are areas of excitement,
things that give us a little,
they're a little bit appealing
to us for one reason or another.
Things we'd really like to get
more into in our life perhaps.
And we need to learn to identify
the more so that we can, uh,
explore new positive things in our life.
So just for a minute, I'd love you to, um,
let's think about someone who made you
either excited, intrigued, or envious,
which are all very interesting words.
You know,
someone you thought other job is really
cool or their way of, uh, you know,
talking to me is really appealing or I'd
really like to have something that they
have.
You don't have to question it too much.
You don't have to feel
guilty about feeling envious.
Because the point here is to try
to take the thing that they have.
It's to try to think about what you
yourself might really be attracted to in
life and that can be a really
helpful thing to know about yourself.
Just for a minute. First things that
come to mind, even if it's a bit strange,
isn't it?
Exercise.
You could also think about
really pleasant, interesting,
unusual experiences you've had recently.
Maybe something that took you by surprise
because it was nicer than you thought
it would be. That's more comfortable, but
I've given you the hard task first. Now,
the easy task, what was really
appealing, what was really nice recently,
once you've written down some of these
hints as to your future interests,
you might begin to unpack them.
So you might think about, well,
now that I've met this person,
what's something that I
might want to explore more or
try more or do differently?
Or if I wanted to get more experiences
like the one that surprised me by being
so nice,
what might I need to do?
The last little section here
says plans from excitement.
It's bed tricky because
it's really thinking about
what you could concretely do
in your life,
like little actual attainable steps that
you could act on as a result of this
excitement.
And perhaps the nicest thing
to do is maybe talk to the
other person next to you.
Just talk to someone slightly different.
Um,
and each of you for a few minutes talk
about what your plans for your excitement
might be. What could you do as a result
of this interesting moment that you had?
So just for a few minutes,
talk to the other person,
the other side of you or you know,
slightly switch your partners and think
about what kinds of plans could you make
in response to this excitement.
Let's share a few,
if you don't mind,
I'd really love to hear
some of your friends,
some of your plans from excitement.
I can yell more loudly with
like triangle and a gong,
but
let's come back together.
You don't mind?
Yeah.
Does anyone have a plan from excitement
that they'd really love to share?
Something that came up that you could do?
No. A moment. That was very exciting.
Oh,
Yup.
Um, I will definitely apply for another
internship at Google. Excellent.
What else?
I think it was a little bit of difficulty
to define what would be the unusual
experience that gets you excited or a
person that gets you extremely excited.
Like to me there was nothing
that's extremely exciting
last time that you can't
stand yourself kind of excitement.
That's moderately exciting.
But that's the thing. I was only
thinking when I read excitement.
I'm thinking of that extreme and like I
couldn't remember anything that's in the
last year probably,
but that does not mean that there
weren't probably smaller things.
They just wouldn't come to your mind
because you never registered them as
exactly like it. It's sometimes hard
for us. We lose track of them. Right?
We often like to say that you should
maybe keep a journal and then the point
isn't to say beautiful, elaborate things.
Every sentence. It's to just take note.
Like that was quite interesting
this morning before you forget.
Otherwise we have less data
available to us effectively.
Really the point here isn't that this
is the only thing we did is called life.
It's rather than, it's just one of
many, many, many things that we do here.
The philosophical meditation.
And the point is that as you mentioned,
we have a lot of unthought thoughts and
unfelt feelings and they can elude us,
but we need time to reflect on them.
Mental good health requires us to
constantly download our minds and sort out
their contents.
And once these things become a little
bit easier to identify the fears and
resentments and hopes,
then it can be a little bit
easier to understand them and be,
become calmer and less resentful and
clearer ultimately about what we want in
life.
MMM.
At this point, I'd love to, first of all,
thank you for coming and sticking with
it even though it's a bit strange.
I know some of it. Um, and I'd
also love to say that, you know,
if you have any questions,
I'm not free and I can answer them or um,
take comments too. Um, so
we were just talking. Yeah.
And I was wondering really
in terms of, um, practicing,
you were mentioning that earlier in
terms of that excitement meditation,
the philosophical meditation.
Yeah.
Do you think that we should be doing
that kind of regularly? Is that yes.
Yeah. Cause it's easy to sit
there and go, oh, you know,
carry on for two years and then go, oh,
now I need to be assessed in my life.
But sometimes, yeah, I think
it's much more useful. I mean,
it's nice that we've
had tastes of it here,
but it's even more useful
as you practice it.
Just like with eastern meditation also,
right? People get better quote unquote,
and meditating, it becomes more
beneficial to them. And in the same way,
the more that we start taking note these
little bits of anxiety and excitement
and upset and so on,
the more likely we are to kind
of generate these very long list.
We can look through and say,
oh look,
these things that have excited me
are related to each other. You know,
are there similar, I tend to
be very excited when I have
spontaneous experiences,
but I don't let myself do that
very much. So we, the more,
the more that we practice it, probably
the more we'll get out of it for sure.
Hi. Yes. Um, uh, you
briefly touched on this,
but I was just wondering what you think
about should this kind of stuff be
taught more formally in school? Cause
I know when I was in school, yeah,
the focus is entirely academic or
athletic and so only kids who excelled in
those things like felt good about
themselves. Um, and there were kids that,
lots of other talents
and yet we're kind of
so they think that in the future.
Um,
we've got a whole section in our blog
actually in our book of life where we talk
about sort of Utopia and um, we talk
about the utopia of education and how, um,
much more of our time probably in the
education system could be well spent
learning some of these
things and practicing some
of these things because first
of all,
like sieves rather than buckets.
We forget a lot of the information
that's given to us in school.
There's so many things we just don't
remember. Um, but second of all,
because information is constantly
more and more available to us,
but the ability to regulate our own
emotions, that takes a lot of time.
You've really got to invest in it and
we'd love to see it more widely available,
especially children and young people,
but also to older people.
We can all learn together like 70 year
olds and seven year olds can be learning
this together actually maybe
in a really useful way.
Um, I get really frustrated when I feel
like people don't have any emotional
intelligence.
Yeah.
Cause I feel like I've got a lot
of it and I request I filled out.
I need that from other people.
How would you suggest that?
I try not to get frustrated
in those situations.
What advice would you give me for
dealing with people that you know,
would see this and they'd be like,
I don't want to go to that talk.
I'm not interested.
Or you know,
they try or you try and explain how you
feel and they're just not interested
because they don't understand it.
Well, first of all, in general about anger
at the school of life and frustration,
we tend to say that, um, uh, our, our
anger is equivalent to our expectations,
right.
If we have very high expectations,
probably they're going to disappoint some
of the time and then our anger will be
very intense as well.
So frankly,
we believe in what we call strategic
pessimism and not just at work,
but in general around people.
They are going to disappoint quite a
bit of the time and it's actually very
helpful to lower our expectations
a little bit to practice. Um,
we really like Seneca,
who's a philosopher and he said that you
should get up in the morning and have a
prayer meditation where you think about
all the things that could go wrong
during the day.
And there's a lot of them.
And the nice thing isn't that at the end
you feel horribly anxious, hopefully,
but that over time you realize,
okay,
well most of these people didn't go to
the emotional intelligence talk and said
really ridiculous emotionally
unintelligent things in the meeting.
But this person actually
said a nice thing.
So it allows us to be less
angry and perhaps less upset,
but also to appreciate more when things
do go well. That's a starting point.
And also you can give them,
you know,
secret gift certificates to the school of
life or something. But thank you. Yeah,
of course. So thank you for the dog. Yeah.
There is this thing called [inaudible],
which is basically I could test
for emotional intelligence. Yeah.
So what do you think of it as a way
of measuring emotional intelligence?
Um, I mean people have made a lot
of tests for this. Uh, it's not,
it's not for me to go and
evaluate that particular test. Um,
in general at the school of life,
we like to test a little bit
more like taking your pulse.
It's a little bit more human sized and
also people change a lot, you know,
and some of these tests might be
more credible than other ones.
So we tend to think it's more useful
if your thinking about your emotional
intelligence rather than if we're telling
you from the outside like this is your
level of emotional intelligence.
Um,
but we do have little tests and
diagnostics you can do for yourself.
And that's a bit more, it's
less like saying, you know,
this is your likelihood of a heart attack.
And it's more like saying,
why don't you take your pulse?
What's your pulse like right now? Um,
so that tends to be our approach to
diagnostics I would say. But you know,
it's nice. Other people are
doing other things I guess.
So you contrast your
approach quite traumatic,
d two regular mindfulness where you
tried to suppress or abstract away from
emotions and kind of, yeah.
Can you elaborate a little bit?
What are the strengths and
weaknesses of each approach?
Yeah, I mean I, I'm not an expert
in eastern mindfulness so I,
I'm going to have to kind of
put that enormous background,
but I'm saying now, um,
some of the types of meditation
that are very common in the west,
which had been through a very complicated
process, translated from much older,
sometimes religious techniques,
um,
tend to allow us to empty our mind in
the sense that they don't focus on the
content of the worry so much
as they ask you to release it.
And that can be a very good thing.
Um,
but one of the reasons we're interested
in examining the contents of the mind is,
are interested in psychology. And
Psychoanalysis and philosophy. Um,
I think there's space for both in the
world and one of the ways that there's
particularly space for both is that it's
important in general to interrogate our
anxieties and our excitement.
But we can't hold onto them forever.
And some of them are not immediately
fixable, like global warming.
We can all do a little bit,
but you know,
if we sit all day long thinking about the
worst case scenario for global warming,
we're going to have a hard time.
So I think the goal is to be able to
sort out from our anxieties, you know,
this one about my relationship
where I have some,
some way of learning and understanding
more and then doing better.
I'm going to really investigate first
and maybe this other one where I can't
really do anything or I'm
a more intelligent approach
will make any difference
because I don't have the
power in that situation.
That might be a really good space.
And mindfulness,
eastern mindfulness has a lot
of other benefits, which again,
I'm not an expert on but are, are
separate as well. Does that make sense?
It's kind of about how much you need to
think about the thing to do better at it
versus where it won't help.
In the beginning you mentioned that you
recommend to be skeptical of your own
emotions and also other people's
emotions. Yeah. Uh, but on the other hand,
we have to be careful not to
dismiss other people's feelings.
When someone comes to me and says they're
anxious, then I don't want to say,
let's see.
It's a reason why it shouldn't be anxious.
Don't think you ain't just to, how do
you strike the balance between this?
Well, this sounds like it's
mostly about people's, um,
not kind of telling people what they're
feeling, which I think is very important.
So I think the idea is more to open up
possibilities before we choose an action
rather than to tell the other
person that they're feeling.
Like if a person comes to us and
they're very angry at us, um,
it's probably more helpful for
us to first ask, you know, um,
maybe some, some mitigating
circumstances like, oh,
this person's under a lot of stress.
This allows me to be slightly
more patient with them.
Or maybe this person is anxious about a
thing I haven't even thought about and I
don't know about it home.
It's not that we then tell them this is
the situation is that we're almost able
to be more curious and ask them and not
immediately judge and rush to action.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Hello? Hi. You were mentioning at the
beginning of the talk defensiveness.
Defensiveness.
Yeah.
And I was just wondering if you are
dealing with people who are extremely
defensive and you, you can see that it's
coming from a place of anxiety or fear,
um, what would your advice to, what
is the best approach in your opinion?
Oh, I mean, there's lots of different
techniques for dealing with defensiveness.
The main thing, first of all, is to deal
with our own defensiveness. It's very,
you know, our school is about changing
ourselves more than other people. Um,
I think the other thing is to remember
that we're defensive because we often
think that our value is attached to
the criticism the person is making.
So we talk a lot, um, in our classes,
especially in our classes around work
that we want to make the criticisms as we
have them enormously local,
right?
So it's that it's very clear to
the person as much as possible.
This isn't about their value as a
human being or even necessarily whether
they're good at their job. It's just
this particular paper online three.
I wonder if we could make
it a little bit more acts.
So one of the things we work on doing is
making criticisms very, very local, um,
because the fear of a person
who's defensive is that
their whole being is being
judged.
Um,
it's also very good to choose the time
and place and manner where you give
criticism and sometimes it's
easier to give it, you know,
out for coffee if you've already had a
nice chat and there's lots of other ways,
but that's a good starting point sometimes
to make it very local and to watch it
in ourselves too.
I feel a bit like I've seen some of
an Ikea catalog. Yeah, definitely.
That's why you've seen 100%. It's right
here. [inaudible] just like, what's the,
what's your next suggested action
as it like signing up for a class,
buying a book.
All those things are good.
We like to do things in
many different formats. Um,
it really depends on what you need.
I can also talk to you
afterwards if you're like, well,
this is the thing I'm most interested in.
Um,
because we know people benefit from
different things depending on what,
what they're facing. Um, I
love our workshops and classes.
I think they're really interesting because
you get to see not just what you're
working with but what other people
are thinking about and going through.
And that is particularly valuable
for me. I really enjoy that, um,
mark yet, but maybe some will be scheduled
and also they happen in our Bloomsbury
classrooms so you can
kind of go and get it.
A taster of some of our business workshops
and also some of our public classes.
But yeah, it is, it's an Ikea catalog.
The whole school of life
in 40 minutes is tough.
Yeah. I think I was just going to ask
a similar question. Um, how could,
you know,
we talked about individuals but also
maybe getting our team to be more aware of
their own emotional intelligence.
Do you do team building
exercises along that front? Yes.
Some of our are about sort of what does
our team need to do in order to do this
or um, some are quite useful in terms of
like allowing the whole group to reflect
together and come up with ideas
and suggestions together. So yeah,
it varies in the topic of course,
how individual versus team built, but
Yup.
Just checking the time. I think
it's 57. Maybe one more question.
I see people are starting to leave. I'll
be here after as well if you have time.
Okay. Okay. Thank you
very much for having us.